[Musique]
des doses mais pas de passion dans les
différents centres de vaccination en
france on estime à plus de 280 mille le
nombre de créneaux disponibles selon
l'application vite ma 12 je demande au
gouvernement que dans le département du
gers avec notre organisation nos dos
nous puissions vacciner des gens qui ont
entre 30 et 60 ans et à ce moment là on
aura une immunité collective qui viendra
beaucoup plus si effectivement les
phénomènes que vous lui dites se
confirme
évidemment nous allons réfléchir à un
élargissement des publics
mais ceci est prématurée ça se passe en
virginie occidentale où l'épidémie ne
faiblit pas pourtant les doses de
vaccins sont disponibles mais les moins
de 35 ans traîne des pieds alors pour
les motiver le gouverneur vient
d'annoncer qu'il allait leur offrir des
bons d'une valeur de 100 $
il s'agit de bons du trésor une sorte d'
épargne qu'il devra permettre de motiver
ces jeunes depuis fin janvier je demande
que l'on puisse ouvrir par exemple la
vaccination aux enseignants à toutes les
professions qui sont en première ligne
et puis plus largement je crois qu'il
faut débrider la question de l'âge dans
l'état de new york pour fêter la
légalisation de la marijuana des
militants ont lancé la semaine dernière
une opération consistant à offrir de
l'herbe aux jeunes vacciner 1 juin le
contrat 25
si on ouvrait au premier venu ça veut
dire qu'une personne prioritaires 60 ans
ou malades ne sera pas vaccinés dans son
offre ne sera pas vacciner aujourd'hui
le sera dans un mois a tendance à dire
que si on élargit on le fait au
détriment des autres forcément l'inde
l'aide internationale commence à arriver
les derniers chiffres qui nous
parviennent ce matin sont effroyables
nombre de morts vient de dépasser les
les 200000 avec plus de 3000 décès ces
dernières 24 heures certains n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'improviser ces
crimes atrium sur les parkings le pays
est le deuxième publié plus peuplé de la
planète est plongé actuellement une
crise sanitaire sans précédent
j'ai peur des positions de marine le pen
j'ai peur de ce qu'elle ferait si
d'aventuré elle était toujours au
pouvoir
on voit bien là le vrai
hb du rassemblement national cf le
rassemblement national c'est un parti de
putschistes sont quand même des gens qui
je le disais tout à l'heure on fait le
choix de donner leur vie dans leur pays
qu'ils sont en train de se faire prendre
des remontrances par des blancs becs
dans marche comme marlène schiappa qui
viennent leur dire comment ils doivent
penser au passé
madame le pen qui profite de toutes les
opportunités devient si j'ose dire
maréchal ont chef d'une armée de
généraux à la retraite qui sont des
factieux et qui pour certains d'entre
eux d'ailleurs cotisent déjà au
rassemblement national
ça fait quelques dizaines d'années j'ai
des recettes multiples réactions que
j'observe à lent déclin lent déclin de
mon pays qui est submergée par une vague
migratoire à contrôler il ya le
communautarisme qui se développe il ya
une insécurité grandissante
oui il ya des risques un risque
d'extrême droite ça c'est clair
quand on voit d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi
la tribune des anciens militaires c'est
un scandale c'est très très dangereux
j'espère et je les ai entendus de la
part de la ministre des armées
j'espère qu'il y aura des sanctions
majeurs sont ces militants du
rassemblement national
j'ai pris ma carte en septembre dernier
et vous avez continué d'être à l'antenne
attendez et vous posez la même question
à quelqu'un qui a sa carte europe
ecologie les verts et la république et
journaliste michael et julie ont eu le
coup de foudre lors d'un test pcr bah
oui elle venait se faire dépister un peu
stressé il a su la rassurer
et depuis ce premier contact par
écouvillon interposée ne se sont plus
quittés
tant mieux si ma démarche ça permet au
moins à 1 montrer que c'est pas parce
que on est journaliste qu'on a ces
cartes au rassemblement oui nationale et
qu'on est un bon à rien je dis est ce
que c'est possible de bacon qu'on garde
un contact quoi
depuis ce fameux jour ils ne se sont
plus jamais quittés
elle sera inaugurée officiellement le 19
mai voilà c'est dans un immeuble de luxe
évidemment à londres une piscine à 35
mètres de hauteur